hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american monster adventure
film called
love and monster spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
the movie begins as joel dawson narrates
to us the current state of the world
he says that his life was normal like
any of us until the end of the world
it all started when a huge asteroid
named agatha 616 was heading straight to
earth
humanity came together and sent several
rockets to destroy the asteroid before
it hit the earth
and succeeded the asteroid was gone
however the rockets were destroyed too
the radioactive material in the rockets
rained back into earth
causing all cold-blooded animals to
mutate so now there are huge ants
roaches crocodiles lizards and many
other huge animals who attack humans
the animals immediately started killing
people and within about a year
95 percent of the human population was
wiped out
the ones who survived hid in bunkers
caves and panic rooms
the surviving humans have been living in
such places for the last seven years
and one of them is joel he lives in a
bunker with other members
the tiny place doesn't provide room for
privacy so joel complains about two of
the members having sex right beside him
as he pretends to sleep
joel tells us that everyone in the
bunker is a couple except for him
their first baby was born last summer
they have established their own
lifestyle vastly different from how it
was outside the bunker
joel's day-to-day life includes milking
the cow and cooking food
they have a hunting party every month in
which some members of the group go up
and bring whatever food they can
joel writes letters to amy his
girlfriend before he lived in the
bunkers
that day joel is practicing hitting
targets when the lights in the bunker
start to flicker
everyone starts to pack their weapons to
go out a mutated animal is in the area
joel asks them if they want his help but
the group tells him to stay in the
bunker
he is a liability for them because joel
cannot fight
the team then leaves to find and kill
the animal joel and a few others stay at
the bunker
they monitor the group through a device
and see that one of the team is killed
by the monster
joel gets a crossbow and goes to help
them one animal has slipped into the
bunker
joel sees it and freezes although he has
plenty of chances to kill it he doesn't
move at all
the animal is about to attack him when
the others from behind him kill it
cut to seven years ago the day the
asteroid was destroyed
joel and his girlfriend amy are in a car
hanging out
he draws a picture of amy and she gives
him a box of colors as a gift
as they kiss the emergency alarm goes
off in the city
just then the pieces of rocket fall back
onto the city creating huge explosions
the two drive back home quickly after
they had come home
everyone was packing their bags to leave
for a safe place
the two hug for the last time separated
that day and have not met ever since
she lives in another colony a few miles
away
seven years later joel still has the box
of colors that he uses to draw the
monster animals on his notepad
that day jay speaks to her through a
radio system
the two talk about the letters that joel
writes to amy every day
but the call cuts off midway others from
the team mourn the death of their team
member
suddenly joel asks the team about amy's
colony
it turns out that it is only 85 miles
away
it takes seven days to reach there joel
is determined to find amy this time
the team members are surprised because
they know joel cannot fight
they try to persuade him to stay but he
packs his bag with all the necessities
and leaves the bunker for the first time
he looks at the map but cannot figure
out anything in it
he even can't tell what direction is
west so
joel takes a chance and heads in a
random direction he walks for a while
thinking that the journey is not as bad
as he expected it to be
on his way he encounters several monster
eggs but tries to stay positive
he finds a frisbee on the ground and
keeps it with him just then
he hears a noise nearby the team members
had advised him to run and hide instead
of fighting the creatures
so joel goes into a nearby house it is
empty as expected
curious he opens the fridge and sees a
creature there he immediately rushes
back outside
he ends up in front of a small pond a
tentacle peeks out of it
joel freezes like he does when he is
scared suddenly
a huge mutated frog comes out of the
pond but joel doesn't move
it attacks joel with its tongue making
him fall to the ground
a dog jumps on top of him out of nowhere
just as joel is about to run
the frog catches his legs with its
tongue and drags him towards them
the dog saves joel from the frog and
they both run to a nearby van
it seems to be the dog's home joel
notices boy written on the ceiling and
figures that it is the dog's name
that night he stays with boy in the van
the following morning
he draws the dog in his notepad thanking
him for saving his life
and continues his journey boy follows
him with his owner's dress
it is the only way boy can still be
close to his owner
joel keeps the dress in his backpack and
starts walking with boy
the two become best friends on their
journey boyd protects joel from eating
poisonous berries and other dangers
while joel tells him everything about
his life one day
as they walk joel falls into a pit the
pit has several burrows inside it
a warm monster called the sand gobbler
comes out from one of the holes and
attacks him
just then two survivors throw him a rope
and bring him out of the pit
several worm monsters attack him as he
climbs up the survivors are a man named
clyde dutton and his eight-year-old
friend
minnow minnow throws an explosive in the
pit and kills the rest of the monsters
as the two strangers continue their
journey joel and boy follow them for
safety
it turns out that mino's father and
clyde son were killed by a monster
and they have been together since then
the duo is heading towards the north now
where fewer monsters live due to the
cold climate and higher elevation
joel decides to be with them until they
have to part ways
suddenly everyone freezes as they come
across a huge snail
climb makes joel take his shirt off and
gives it to the snail
his shirt had the smell of sand gobblers
in them which attracted other monsters
now the snail will spread it through the
jungle and help them confuse the
monsters
the snail slowly leaves minnow teaches
joel that like the snail
some creatures are actually nice you can
tell by their eyes
for the next two days they teach joel to
shoot a crossbow in the right direction
and other survival skills
joel draws every monster they come
across the day finally comes when they
have to part ways
minnow insists he come with them to the
north but joel has to find amy
clyde gives joel a grenade as a parting
gift as joel and boy continue heading
west
boys suddenly feels something is wrong
and hides joel tries to bring him out
but before he can he is attacked by a
huge centipede monster
like the one he had encountered in the
bunker this time dole manages to point
his crossbow at him but freezes right
after
the monster throws him away with its
tail and surrounds boy
joel lies on the ground thinking of the
day his parents died
with much determination he gets up and
shoots at the monster
killing him he finally saves boy and the
two celebrate
that night they stay at a motel where
they encounter a talking robot named
mavis
the robot has 51 minutes of battery left
joel asks her if she has a working
outlet that he can use his radio
on mavis offers her remaining battery to
him
joel finally contacts amy who is worried
about him
she tells him that her colony is leaving
for a new place very soon
they have found another group of
survivors who plan to take them
somewhere safe
before she can tell him where they are
going the power runs out
joel brings mavis outside and talks to
her about his feelings
the robot shows him the picture of his
family through its database
she plays a song for them when suddenly
her battery dies
boy and joel continue their journey the
following day
as they walk they encounter a queen sand
gobbler
clyde had warned them about her being
the most dangerous of them all
the queen attacks them and chases them
through the woods joel and boy hide by a
river
however boy gets scared and starts
barking giving away their position
boy's owner's dress falls into the river
which makes him get out of hiding
the queen finds their location but
before she can attack them
joel uses the grenade to kill her he
falls into the water before the
explosion
when he gets out of the water he finds
several leeches latch onto his body
he screams at boy for giving away their
location earlier
saddened boy runs away from him joel now
walks alone
but the leeches seem to have poisoned
him with something he gets light-headed
and starts to hallucinate
just then a group of people appears
before him he opens his eyes to see amy
in front of him
amy is surprised to see him too the two
kiss
but joel falls unconscious soon after
that when he wakes up he is in a bunker
amy greets him as it turns out that he
had kissed an old man earlier
the two are talking when amy is called
by another older woman
after her parents died amy has been in
this colony taking care of the elderly
people there
she is the head of the colony as the
elders depend on her
they live on a beach joel goes outside
and sees the beautiful view
several people are packing to leave the
place another group of survivors had
approached amy's colony
their leader cap had promised to take
them to a safer arena
so now they are packing to leave joel
meets cap who is preparing for a party
at night
camp brews his own beer which is the
attraction of the party
later that day amy confesses she is glad
to see joel
but has no romantic interest in him she
has grown into a different person now
and is mourning the death of a close one
suggesting that she was together with
someone else all these years before he
died
joel is devastated and apologizes to her
for not asking before coming to see her
amy assures him that it is okay and
invites him to join their colony
however joel decides to return back to
his colony and contacts them through the
radio
his friends are happy and surprised to
find out he is alive
they inform him that the bunker is no
longer safe for them and that they are
planning to leave soon
the phone cuts off midway joel then
notices the berries and beer kept beside
him by one of cap's friends
he sees that the berries are poisonous
the one that boy had warned him about
earlier
joel realizes that cap and his crew are
planning to poison the other survivors
he goes out to tell amy but she is too
drunk to understand
just then someone hits him on the head
and he falls unconscious
the following morning joel wakes up to
him tied up on the beach
the others are in the same condition cap
reveals that he and his crew are
actually pirates who raid colonies for
food and fuel
he summons a crab monster rigged with a
makeshift electric collar to eat the
colonists
they also use the crab to toe their
yacht as the crab attacks them amy frees
herself and joel
she runs to fight the crew and leaves
joel to fight the monster crab
amy fights with the girl member of the
crew joel surprisingly manages to push
the crab over
but cap electrocutes the crab and it
hits joel making him fall unconscious
the crab then walks towards joel as he
retreats just then
boy comes to his aid as dana aims to
shoot boy amy hits her
making her shoot the crab instead cap's
crew runs to the boat and gets back on
their yacht
the crab is about to kill joel when he
looks at its eyes and notices that it is
actually a friendly animal
it had gone wild because cap
electrocuted it so
joel shoots at the chain that
electrocutes it which makes the crab
docile again
it leaves the beach and goes to capsics
to kill all of them
later that day joel packs his bag to get
back to his colony to help them
he gives his book of monsters to amy as
a parting gift and they kiss their
goodbye
we see joel survive the seven day
journey back to the bunker with boy
he finally meets his friends again they
too decide to head to a safe place in
the mountains
on the radio joel inspires other
colonies to come out to the surface
proving that life outside is still
possible in the end
we see many colonies head towards the
mountains to live a better life
clyde and minnow are already there while
joel and boy are also heading towards
the mountain
trying to survive the next journey
subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching